Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab,
the podcast and a this week on the podcast we did a collaborative thing with our
friends at on the media,
a wonderful show produced here at Wny c we decided to give them a headache when
I was a very provocative idea brought to us by Jonah Lehrer,
one of our regular contributors and we just couldn't get it out of our heads.
It was such spooky. Yes.
It begins with the work of a psychology professor, Jonathan Schooler,
who many years ago to great acclaim,
got a bunch of people in a room together and he had them watch a video basically
watch this bank robber walk into a bank and he hands a note to the Clark and he
says, don't press the alarm and you won't get hurt.
Clerk then hands him some money and he exits and these people watching the
video, do they get a good look at the guy you got a straight on look at the bank
robber. Absolutely. And here is the test. After everybody watched this thing,
he had half the subjects only half right down in as much detail for five
minutes. Everything they could remember about the appearance of the bank robber.
So they'd write, you know, really brown hair, mustache, thick glasses,
whatever it was. They just described the guy that they just seen.
Now only half of them did this, the other half did nothing.
And then later he had all the subjects.
Look at a police lineup and try and identify the robber, pick the bank robbers,
see if you can pick them. Yeah, no,
you would think that the people who had to describe the guy right after seeing
him the first time, they would do really well at this. You know,
cause they had kinda set the memory. Yeah. That's not what they found.
We found those people who had been asked to describe the face in great detail,
they were actually less good at recognizing the face than if they didn't engage
in any description at all. Not just a little less good.
They were like 30 or 40% less good. So it was pretty whopping.
Whopping in just odd. Yeah.
Even more odd is that as he did more studies,
he found it wasn't just a face thing.
It happens when you try to remember all kinds of stuff.
He found the effect with colors.
We found it later on with tastes choices.
The effect was so strong and in so many different places that he gave it a name.
Verbal overshadowing, verbal. The words overshadow the truth. Yeah.
So there's some association here is when you talked about it, you get it wrong.
Exactly. So we should say these studies, uh,
made schooler into kind of a rock star. Yeah, I did get it. Got Some press, uh,
at the time and he appeared everywhere really including on a little show called
radio lab. He was even here.
And this is where our story really begins because just as people like us were
getting very excited about his work, the data began to go a little funny on him.
That's right.
And it all began when he tried to replicate that original experiment. Yes.
As you kept doing it. What happened? Well, uh, over the years,
over the next five or six years, when I attempted to do it again,
I would get the effect, but not to the same degree that I did initially.
And this is, this is a little troubling for him.
That's Jonah Lehrer science writer, one of our contributing editors.
He turned us onto this story and it went like this.
He says the first time school or tries to replicate that study, that effect
falls by 30%. And so he tried it again and again.
And as we kept trying to replicate this study,
the effect size got smaller and smaller and smaller,
meaning that big difference between the people who wrote about the bank robber
and got it wrong. And people who didn't write about the bank, they right,
and they got it right. That big difference began to decline.
This slow downward trajectory
did sort of gradually get smaller. It wasn't as if all of a sudden it,
it just
here now, it's still significant. It's still publishable,
but it's not nearly as exciting as it was that first time.
So, as you can imagine,
Jonathan schoolers sitting in in his office and he was like,
what is happening here? I mean, it was so good the first time,
and then it started to phase a very good experimental psychologist.
He's not sloppy or anything. No. So He's thinking what's happening here?
And the first theory he has to really wrestle with is something known as
regression to the mean. I mean, those are three of the most uninstall. Yeah.
Byard words put together there words though.
It's to mean, but Jonah, can you make it concrete for us? Sure.
So you flip a coin, right? Let's say you'll flip a coin 10 times.
You may get eight heads in details, and you may say, oh my gosh,
I've discovered a new law of coin flipping. When I flip coins in this room.
They are almost always heads. But if you kept on flipping that coin for say,
a thousand times, your data would show almost certainly,
unless you really had discovered something very peculiar about that room,
the results would get closer to the true result, which is about 50%.
The results would regress to the mean. Hmm,
sorry. Any case. His first thought was maybe that's what's going on here. Yeah.
Meaning when we first did the study for whatever reason we got lucky or unlucky
as the case may be
you, you saw an outlier. Exactly. That reality is full of quirky surprises.
We can't explain, but over time,
and this is the miracle of the scientific process, you,
you regressed to the true effect size.
But one thing about the regression to the mean account is it doesn't really
explain why the effects gradually get smaller regression to the mean you predict
one big effect and then it should basically totter around the actual value.
This gradual decline doesn't naturally fall out of the regression to the mean
account. Yeah, I mean the effect could just go away.
In which case you knew you were wrong, but why would it sudden slowly get worse?
Well,
one possible explanation is that there was some aspect to the procedure that was
important that we never really realized was important and somehow we were
gradually not including whatever that secret ingredient was.
Meaning you as a scientist when you try and do an experiment,
you try and do it the same way every time down to the,
to the floss that you floss your teeth with before you did the experiment,
but the too many things that you may not pay attention to it.
It may be some little thing off into the side that you're not even thinking
about. It could have been the color of the room in which he was conducting the
experiments. It could of been how charming his Grad student was.
Who was actually asking the students to describe the bank robber.
Totally making up the story here. Let's say that Gretchen was so charming,
so good looking, so charismatic that he distracted the students.
Then the Grad student goes off,
leaves the lab and has got a much less exciting Grad students on Eylea as
distracting and now the effect size of verbal overshadowing has gone down.
But the only problem with that is that that little sound that Jen and I made
means that you have to have your terming grad student at the beginning and your
less charming Grad student in the middle, and you're even less grad student.
Yeah. They have to get slowly less charming. That's right.
And so if you're thinking something is changing here, what is it?
What is it? What is it?
Did you go on some kind of math search to figure out what you might be doing
differently? We tried lots, a lot of different things. And in the end,
I just moved to another area of research.
We got out of town and apparently one of schoolers,
colleagues told him, don't worry about it.
The only mistake you made was trying to replicate it in the first place. Yeah.
But, uh, here's the problem.
Turns out it's not just me who has experienced this peculiar decline effect.
As he started to look around,
he realized what was happening to him was happening all over the place. Oh,
are scientists in all kinds of other sciences?
We're having the exact same problem in biology. There was a uh,
Meta analysis of many different biological findings showing there are a ton of
examples. These has, and here's one.
In the 90s there were a bunch of studies about uh,
animals using symmetry to find mates like birds,
females and female birds,
choosing their sexual partners based on how even the males tail feathers were.
It was a very exciting idea and the first year there were eight tests of it and
all eight found the, Yep. Fluctuating asymmetry.
That's what the phenomenon is called is real. We also got an effect size,
so it seemed true. Yeah.
They're all over the world and all of these different species,
females had evolved this unconscious tendency to prefer symmetrical males.
The next year it's tested 12 times and nine of the 12 confirm it and then things
start to fall apart.
You can make the sound effect the exactly until by the end of the nineties
you're going one for 13 one for 13 one one for 13 now of course these studies
were not black and white. Yes, no studies. There's some gradation,
but this was the basic trend that Jonah's saw.
And just in case birds seem a little distant.
Here's another example and I think this is for me the most troubling, um,
area that decline effect. Um,
cause you see like second generation antipsychotics,
second generation anti-psychotic,
these are drugs used to treat people with schizophrenia. Bipolar,
when they first came out in the late eighties, early nineties,
some studies found that they were about twice as effective than first generation
antipsychotics. Um,
and then what happened is the standard story of the decline effect Q,
the sound effect, um,
which is clinical trial after clinical trial,
the effect size just slowly started to fall apart. And, uh, that's not all.
You see a similar decline with things like Prozac. Um,
and instead of precedence, the effect of the drugs have gotten weaker,
but the placebo effect has also gotten stronger. Um,
I was talking to one guy to drug company who he was kind of interesting.
He blamed that on drug advertising.
He said that they started to see their placebo effect go up in the late nineties
when these drug companies started advertising.
Wouldn't that actually offer an explanation for this decline thing because you
know some, if you know about what this drug is supposed to do,
maybe it works differently. Some of them,
certainly there are areas of psychology where that can change the outcome and in
one way or another, but uh,
it's very unlikely that you know and say these female preferences for a
symmetrical feathers that the, you know,
the birds got wind of the symmetry finding and now all of a sudden they've not
got into it anymore. I don't know.
You haven't been around chickadee conversation weird,
fast as quickly amongst the chickadees. And so does that mean that you,
can you explain why what you found at the beginning is not what you find now and
why it is why it gradually went away? The gradually is still puzzling.
I tell you, I find it very puzzling to,
I'm personally baffled.
It's tough to come up with an all purpose explanation or some easy fix.
It could be a lot of different things bundled together into one phenomenon.
He says, you know,
maybe in some cases it really is statistics rushing to the mean is almost sure
to be a part of it. And maybe in some cases it's, you know,
this gradual change in the procedure and something that we just don't know what
it was that happened. Can't rule it out.
But I would probably be less shocked than most people if something
unconventional was actually involved in this as well.
Unconventional. Like, like I say this, uh, with, uh,
some trepidation,
but I think we can't rule out the possibility that there could be some way in
which the act of observation is actually changing the nature of reality.
That somehow in the process of observing effects,
we changed the nature of those effects. Ah, you're in real trouble.
Yeah.
Essentially what he's saying we think is that when he discovered that thing with
the bank robber experiment,
maybe the discovery itself somehow sit in motion a series of events that made
the thing he discovered start to sort of run away. Well, I'm not your,
I'm going to say that. I'm
certainly not going to say that there's some sort of intentionality to these
effects a disappearing more that it's almost, and again,
this is just a speculation, some sort of habituation,
so just as when you put your hand on your leg, you feel it,
and then as you leave it there, it becomes less and less noticeable somehow.
There may be some kind of habituation that happens in with respect to these
findings.
What is the hand and what is the leg in, in, in, in this?
Well, in in the, in this most radical conjecture,
there could be some sort of collective consciousness that's habituating. Again,
radical speculation.
Keep in mind the notion that the laws of reality are unchangeable is an
assumption. It's a reasonable assumption, but we don't know it for a fact.
In there have been a physicists who have even speculated that perhaps the rules
change as time goes on.
[inaudible]
the problem with this idea is if you really believe it,
then you can never really know anything.
We're sliding into that creditor door like you know by this logic,
you could never really know for sure. Yes.
Because reality could change based upon the observers,
position, habits, biases, information, whatever.
So far we have not really seen these types of things in the domain of,
of physics, but you know, and aspirin might not do what it used to. Huh.
There's a question that you haven't asked, which is,
let's say that we were to do a study and demonstrate this decline effect,
that when you keep running experiments that they get smaller. Well,
what happens when you try to replicate that effect? Does it decline, effect,
decline? Yeah, that's a good question.
Maybe we could just get rid of the decline effect by studying it,
but then
if you were to study the decline of the decline effect than it would on decline
and it would come back. You can see what I'm saying. I see what you're saying.
You're just stuck forever in the great seesaw of the universe.
We should thank our, uh, our friends at, on the media,
on the media as a show that analyzes, you know, the media as I'm sure you know.
And it's an amazing show. I mean, it's an amazing show. Uh,
Brooke and Bob who hosts the show are, are funny,
hysterically funny and brilliantly smart,
and it's the kind of show that it's just kind of essential.
It's one of those shows. I could not recommend it more on the media.org.
All one word on the media.org check it out.
They're going to do an entire hour on the subject of data and we have sort of
snuck this issue that we've just talked about into the middle of that show.
So it's a, it's the same thing, but in a very different context than you can.
You can go to their podcast on Friday the 13th of May and there it,
and we felt that until it, and we declined. Yup. Into oblivion.
I'm Jad Abumrad I was and will continue to be, I hope for the moment.
Robert Foley back.